we have a mutual friend in common
big j okerson yes i just talked to him
yesterday
i'm nice man i love that guy we took him
out on tour uh we did this tour
with uh the acremeister that was years
back
and he was he opened for us right so for
the people who don't know who big
jokerson is
he's uh a stand-up comedian yeah
an absolute master of crowd work he's
just the funniest guy
i've i performed with him very early in
my stand-up career
and i forget if it was like jokes that
he i think he had a story about
opening for corn and that like the
picture he painted of it was that trying
to do stand-up comedy for uh you know in
an arena for a rock and roll band
as an opener is like
it doesn't always work so like you're
doing stand-up in montreal at that
rock fest it was it was all right but it
was the best part of this act was
all the hecklers he would just tear them
new asses it was amazing
yeah how did you guys come up with the
idea to get big j
to open for you um it just came around i
mean they just asked if we would be down
for that i think it came with the
sponsors and all that and they said hey
we want to have this guy come out and do
comedy and we're like
that should okay i hope he's good he's
ready to get [ __ ] thrown at him
but he he really did great it wasn't
like that every night i'd go out and
watch him
my favorite part was when people would
talk [ __ ] he would just tear them
apart it was amazing yeah he's quick
with the crowd
crowd work he's super funny he's a good
guy
yeah dude so you were talking to him
just yesterday huh like
you talked to him frequently yeah we
kept in touch
over the years um when we play in new
york he comes out to our shows and
i just saw that someone tried just body
slammed him off the stage the other
night
oh my god dude i i thought that like
oh he got knocked out of pennsylvania
then i saw the footage like last night
and dude it was
violent yeah it was violent that guy
that was because he was talking
[ __ ] someone was talking [ __ ] to him and
he was doing what he does and then just
some guy came up from behind and
and got him someone was like man you
gotta chill bro
this is some that's crazy coming up on
stage
i he says he's okay but man he took a
hard fall off that stage the guy just
that was [ __ ] up so he just like
checked him off the stage
oh he just grabbed him and took him off
the stage
yeah he was sitting on a stool the guy
grabbed his uh
feet and the stage was a good five feet
off the ground so the guy grabbed his
feet yanks him off the stool
and he comes forward all the way to the
ground in front of the stage and lands
like flat on his back which is
not healthy jeez no jonathan have you
dealt with a lot of unruly crowds
yourself
yeah dude